got some breaking news coming out of
france for you in the last couple of
minutes an orthodox
priest has been injured in a shooting
this took place in the french city of
lyon and we're told that the assailant
has fled
a police source telling reuters
we understand that police are currently
uh undertaking a manhunt the priest was
fired on twice at around four o'clock
local time as he was close to the church
and
was being treated on-site for
life-threatening injuries uh this is
according to
the uh french police source just to tell
you one more time an orthodox priest has
been injured in a shooting in the french
city
of lyon and the assailant has fled i'm
being told that our correspondent mark
white
is in france for us mark what more can
you tell us
exactly what the french authorities had
feared and the very reason that they put
this country
on the highest state of alert uh the
prospect potentially of more terrorist
attacks and it certainly looks
on the face of it from what is unfolding
in the city of lyon
that we may be looking at another
terrorist incident
uh getting it now reported from multiple
sources both french
media and reuters news agency quoting
the interior minister reporting that a
serious incident
has unfolded in leon the specifics of
that
a shooting outside an orthodox church
priest we're told shot and very
seriously injured he's being treated
at the scene by french paramedics uh two
shots fired we're told just after
4 p.m local time this afternoon uh
that priest we are also told was locking
up
outside this orthodox church at the time
of the shooting now in addition to this
and this is of course
very serious and very worrying uh we
have
a suspect an assailant on the run at
this time
according to french authorities again
being quoted
by french media the assailant
has not been apprehended or in any way
neutralized at this point
so whoever is responsible for the
shooting of this
priest outside an orthodox church is
still at large at this hour and that is
of great concern because
clearly this individual is armed with
some kind
of weapon a handgun or an automatic
weapon
we don't know at this stage the details
are still coming through it's really
just happened
uh within the last hour that area
in the seventh iron dismal of leon has
been
sealed off emergency services are at the
scene there is
a massive manhunt now being launched in
leon to find
the perpetrator responsible for this
attack and that will give great concern
of course
to the authorities throughout the
country as i say this is why
we are on the high state of security
alert in this country